or because our covid numbers are going
up the southern nevada health district
is now recommending mask wearing
indoors for everyone regardless of your
vaccination status
and local businesses are trying to
figure out what next steps to take
oracle manage joining us live with what
some now
plan to do orco
well brian it's a big question for a lot
of businesses in las vegas
should they ask patrons to wear masks
the businesses we spoke to tonight
have different answers you're going to
have to breathe
you know at some point real results
fitness in downtown las vegas will not
require mass for anyone despite new
recommendations from the southern nevada
health district
it's up to the clients you know it's
their discretion if
they feel safer wearing a mask by all
means they can but we're not going to
enforce it right now but the gym
is keeping extra sanitation and social
distancing measures in place
we actually still use the squares
because we have no idea what's going to
happen the health district announced
friday everyone vaccinated or not should
wear masks indoors citing a rising covet
19 cases
and slowing vaccination rates in clark
county
employees at local pawn shop max pond
will be wearing masks and they'll ask
all customers to do so
too let's all play by the same rules the
county and the
health district have come up with this
recommendation for a reason
it's health based but what if someone
won't wear one we're not going to shoot
away business
health experts understand this creates a
gray zone but hope businesses make the
right decision
because this delta variant spreads like
wildfire even in the face of vaccinated
people
real results fitness says it'll make
changes once it needs to
when there is a mandate we will follow
the rules and the law accordingly
the hospitality industry is also
weighing the new recommendation from the
health district
both the venetian and the westgate
announced today that they're requiring
mass for employees
but not customers reporting live from
downtown las vegas tonight orca mana 8
news now